Hey, what do you want to be? You
can be anything here.
This is Eide
Academy. It's a school for kids who want to play an active role in the virtual world.
Every day, many students here
take various classes in order to become who they want to be.  I want to be
like my idol Kizuna Ai-chan, so I'm
working hard every day,
but because I'm
acting on my own momentum, I often
fail.But I want to connect with many people, so I
'm working hard without giving up.This
girl is my classmate Chris, and she's really cute.
Miraku's performance was so close to my face that
she was amazing and seemed to be interested in me for some reason.She was so sparkly that she learned how to dance just after seeing her once.She is very
good at singing and dancing, and is a popular virtual
artist.  He works harder than anyone else and is
very dependable.I want to
be the perfect virtual artist that I aim to be.He is very skilled with
rhythm and can use
anything he does to improve his activities as a virtual artist.I have to
follow his
example.  She's a quiet girl,
but she
's a kind person who supports us well.The unit made up of me, Mirak, and
Chris
Kuon is a bust.LiveWe have
different personalities and personalities,
but that's why we're able to move forward together.  There must
be a world that I can see. I want to
connect more and more with my friends as I aim to become a virtual artist like Kizuna Ai. The
Ariel of Bonds will start broadcasting in 2023
[Music]